back in Britain after cutting short his
stay in the Dominican Republic his third
holiday since he resigned in July former
prime minister Boris Johnson's
considering going for the top job again
after Liz trussy's government collapsed
but to say that Prospect is divisive
would be an understatement good morning
currently former Chancellor Rishi sunak
who resigned during the last days of the
Johnson Premiership has the most
supporters among conservative MPS he's
not spoken yet
I've done some amazing things in my life
I've had a seat at the table at the
World Bank in NATO the leader of the
commons penny mordant is also trying
again after losing out to trust in last
month's leadership contest
if more than one candidate has the
backing of at least 100 MPS on Monday
the decision then goes to around 150 000
conservative party members
they could well back Johnson who quit
after dozens of his MPS resigned
following scandals including
rule-breaking parties in Downing street
during covid-19 lockdowns but one
well-known figure who served under
Johnson says it's not time for him to
return with a parliamentary inquiry
still looming at the job of any Cabinet
member let alone the prime minister is
just relentlessly consistently be
concentrated with a laser-like focus on
the British people from the economy
through to the NHS schools crime
immigration it's difficult to see how
you could do that if at the same time
you're giving evidence giving testimony
will be caught back in the Groundhog Day
the political uh soap opera of partygate
some conservative MPS have already said
they'd leave the party if Johnson became
prime minister again
there is a question mark about whether
or not Mr Johnson could create a stable
and Effective Government and to be
honest the same question has to be asked
about Mr Suna there are people out there
who are in the anybody but Mr sunak
can't they blame him for Mr Johnson's
downfall much of the public say they're
tired of the instability in government
and one opinion poll suggests nearly
two-thirds one whoever emerges as new
conservative leader and hence prime
minister to call an early general
election of course events could always
force them to do so Nadine barber Al
Jazeera London